[Música]
porque la sociedad y la velocidad del
mundo actual nos obliga a estar
corriendo un lado para otros sin embargo
y de prisa no implica necesariamente
pensar de forma más ágil hacer las cosas
mejor o tachar más rápido de nuestras
vidas nuestras obligaciones de la lista
no vivimos a un ritmo acelerado sentimos
la necesidad de ser productivos de hacer
una cosa tras otra y de vivir de forma
inmediata al final del día disfrutamos
de los pequeños detalles de la vida no
hacerlo nos puede generar frustración
ansiedad y hasta terminar en depresión
vivimos entonces cumpliendo lo urgente y
dejando a un lado lo importante para
ello quiero saludar en ese momento a
pablo me litio él es el psicólogo y
escritor pablo gracias por estar aquí
con nosotros en directo américa de
france 24 para hablar de nuestra vida la
rapidez en la inmediatez entonces la
inmediatez entonces le pregunto la
lentitud y lo inesperado no tienen
también su lugar en nuestras vidas ahora
ya urbanizadas
bueno buen día un placer dialogar con
cómodos con ustedes bueno hay que
practicar el arte de la lentitud lo
opuesto no porque esta sociedad tiene
una arquitectura mental una estructura
funcionamiento desde el acelere desde la
ansiedad me parece que es un imperativo
que hay que estar siempre acá decimos a
ameal azul a toda máquina sin embargo
creo que eso tiene que ver con la
ansiedad que es el mal de la época no la
ansiedad el plus de ansiedad no
justamente que es lo opuesto a lo que el
ser humano necesita que para no caer en
trastornos mentales y respirar estar en
calma tomarse las cosas de una manera
más tranquila pero bueno hay que
oponerse al imperativo social justamente
no para trabajar de esa manera ahora la
búsqueda satisfacer nuestras necesidades
nuestros anhelos o nuestros deseos hasta
cuando lo vamos a lo vamos a hacer
cuando se va a tener esto
creo que se va a detener cuando no nos
compremos
este imperativo que es pero yo desde el
capitalismo mismo que el tiempo tiene
que ser siempre productivo tenemos que
estar siempre haciendo cosas la
hiperactividad como como si fuera algo
normal me parece que una medida que no
empecemos a comprender que cada persona
tiene su tiempo interno que cada uno
tiene que contar su forma de ser y estar
en el mundo hasta que nos podamos tener
un bien ser nunca va a haber un
bienestar y nunca mi bienestar va a ser
en función de practicar todo el tiempo
el acelere y terminar con un trastorno
de ansiedad por no poder pararlo y es
que eso le quería comentar porque
nosotros queremos ya todo inmediato al
no tenerlo entonces viene la frustración
viene también nuestra ansiedad cómo
poder manejarlo
claro me parece que lo que hay que
pensar es que tanto la ansiedad como la
angustia son sentimientos normales del
ser humano en este tiempo como te decía
al principio nos exigen si estar por
encima de las posibilidades que tenemos
por eso después se paga con síntoma no
no es extraño que al consultorio del
psicólogo lleguen personas con
trastornos de ansiedad por altísimos
niveles de acelere entonces en
definitiva lo que termina pasando es que
aparecen síntomas y posiblemente
patologías o psicopatologías en función
de este ritmo acelere de vida cómo se
resuelve esto bueno pues como decía en
un principio volver al tiempo interno
de manera más calma la vida parece fácil
decirlo la práctica implica si detenerse
un poco la práctica implica conectarse
con la respiración con el cuerpo
preguntar detrás de que estoy yendo no
es la zanahoria que impone la sociedad
que impone la cultura es realmente a
donde yo quiero ir
tenemos que volver a las preguntas
existenciales y singulares es decir que
quiero para mi vida que quiero que
quiero para mí no que quiero mostrarle a
la sociedad porque sino que terminar
bajo el imperativo de el éxito y de
logros que no son los míos quizás son
los que me imprimen desde afuera en un
cierto y eso terminó como desgastando lo
que decimos la subjetividad en cada uno
lo que cada uno quiere pablo también
estamos buscando en nuestras sociedades
la felicidad la perfección felicidad a
toda costa felicidad felicidad felicidad
eso es lo que nos vende el mundo ahora
pero también que tanto hay cabida y que
tan necesarias son las tristezas la
frustración y los fracasos para poder
pues vivir una vida lo más mentalmente
sana posible lo más equilibrada porque
tampoco está bien siempre estar feliz
feliz feliz feliz feliz
clancy
ahí lo mismo es muy interesante esto que
traes porque es feliz feliz feliz todo
el tiempo feliz todo el tiempo alegre no
es posible no es humano ser humano
también es conectar con el vacío
existencial ser humano también es a
veces estar triste no tener ganas de
hacer cosas me parece que estar detrás
de la búsqueda permanente del goce del
plus de goce de estar siempre gozando
disfrutando la vida termina cayendo en
un vacío muy grande porque tarde o
temprano como bien señalaba podés caer
en la sensación de frustración se puede
estar bien todo el tiempo no es humano
entonces si no vas a terminar como el
libro de euler un mundo feliz buscando
la pastillita asoma que no se estabilice
las emociones lo más interesante del ser
humano es los cambios emocionales no
conectar con con la diversidad de
emociones que tenemos a veces cada día
por supuesto que si saltamos desde una
gran angustia a una gran ansiedad puede
ser este perjudicial pero por momentos
están un poco tristes estar alegres me
parece que a veces la vida común si yo
donde te vas encontrando con con
compuertas que te conectan con
diferentes emociones y hay que conectar
con esas emociones y sentirse no
sentirse porque la salud mental tiene
que ver con el logro de un equilibrio
psico emocional
si físico y social no entonces todo ese
combo es difícil ajustarlo conseguir ese
bienestar bueno sea un tiempo
pues pablo gracias por hablar con
nosotros por estar teniendo esta
conversación sobre la vida sobre la
felicidad sobre las frustraciones y
luego también en un entorno de pandemia
la salida de esta pandemia de cohetes y
nueve que tanto nos tocó emocionalmente
pablo gracias por su tiempo
no un placer herido para cerrar lo de la
pandemia también nos enseñó esto no que
lo más importante es cuidarnos y cuidar
a los demás entonces en esa sociedad un
poquito más justa la salud mental
también va a tener su estabilidad